I have to know for you as an actor
you're filming more romantic style
scenes what has that been like oh so
awkward for us yes for you oh my god
it's the first time I feel like seems
like that I want to talk to you about
the female orgasm it's a fellow MRSA so
excited we're here on season 4 of one
day at a time yes we can hear the crew
over there I want to take it back I want
to just rewind a little bit you know you
get some unfortunate news that the show
is coming to a halt but then three
months later you get a phone call that
we are coming back want to know about
was it and how did you react it was the
worst of course so who did call you and
let you know we're back it was an email
from was it from Gloria from all of them
brain oh okay and why was your reaction
and what was the expression on your face
and Queen Isabella I have to know was it
a phone call was it an email how did you
find out I got a text okay I got a text
because I was actually in I had just
landed in Barcelona and I was doing a
convention
and I had been texting with mica Gloria
the day before I was like what's
happening look it had been a few weeks
of like back and forth and I mean like
it's not gonna happen wait it might
happen and I mean in the immigration
line and I went with my parents but my
mom and I traveled separately from my
dad so I'm in the immigration line
you're not supposed to have phones so
I'm just like sneaking texts and it was
Gloria and Mike I didn't get Brent
whatever and it was just like we got the
show back and I wanted to tell my
parents together and I was in an
immigration line so I just like very
quietly squealed Lisa I was just like oh
it's first of all really rare that a
show get a second life but also
sometimes when shows get a second life
some of the actors have taken other jobs
or people are all of a sudden
unavailable
oh we were under contract oh okay so so
you guys deal they run to hold us
because they really want to get us back
okay so if you came back you had to come
back
you had to come and we were gonna come
we would have come back but we've had to
come back I mean and what does it mean
to you to have the entire Alvarez family
and and friends of course all back
together on this set it's so weird I
think for the first two weeks straight
up season before I was like is this what
are we what because wheat from the time
we've wrapped season three to now it was
a year and a half so so much happened
and it's just kind of the most lovely
because it feels like we just kind of
picked right back up where we left off I
remember like the first table read that
we did of the first episode we all
looked at each other like that was
really yeah it's totally normal the
energy is great we're all really happy
having fun laughing and just wanting to
I made you a profile of tinder says
lonely Catholic nurse seeks big strong
man to fill the hole in her life you
might want to reword that this seems to
be a lot going on with both of your
characters in season four a lot of life
changes as always let's talk about Elena
for a second what is in store for season
four well without saying too much island
it's a scene here now so she is looking
at colleges and she is trying to figure
out what she's gonna do with her life
next
and what that entails for the rest of
our life for her love live would sit and
what that means when they both go to
college and what it means to maybe leave
home or not or where that's gonna look
like and also they've been in a
relationship for a long time now so just
kind of figuring out where that's gonna
go and it's a lot more serious now and
if they want to keep pursuing better
what's next I mean how is their
relationship at this current moment do
you think they're gonna stay together if
you guys go to different colleges in
different parts of the country or the
world I have no idea I think either way
would be really interesting because
people do both I feel like this couple
in particular would maybe try a
long-distance cuz they're so weird
together I'm so good together we're
filming a TV show this is real yeah I
don't know I'm not sure okay yeah and as
far as college is concerned do you think
Elena is gonna leave the coop and say
goodbye to the family for a sec actor
Isabella says he'll know why because
then I wouldn't be on the show oh look
we can build you a classroom on this we
could George View School is Yale so
there's so maybe yes it is a possibility
totally is so it's gonna dump me aren't
they
I always assumed I would be the dumper
not that don't we
alehna and SIDS relationship we know is
is pretty rock-solid but there could be
some outside temptation what do you have
to say about that I have to say they're
rock solid but they're young and they
have to learn some stuff and a lot of
times you learned through making
mistakes say about do you think sit in a
Lenna our end game I feel like the fans
would really come at me if I said no
yeah we're working for come on
possibly here's the thing they're so
young and I think especially for the
kind of people they are they would maybe
definitely like split and be like let's
live life time apart and then come back
together so maybe their end game in that
way okay yeah that's fair and that's
gold yeah somebody opens the door that
they shouldn't you walked in on our he
walked in under Alex gets a little
romance this season what can you tell us
about that well um we've done an episode
right now where it's me and Nora which
is my girlfriend yeah and yeah it was
kind of awkward no he's hurt at all
Harry I was awkward for algata Lorne but
it was he's like you know all the
personalities in my family my mom Elena
always talking about school and
everything
and especially Rita being jealous of
course yes it's a lot to deal with
of course so that's something but she's
awesome and I feel like finally he spent
a lot of time with Sid in Atlanta he
deserves a little emotional I have to
know for you as an actor you're filming
more romantic style scenes what has that
been like oh so awkward for us yes for
you oh my god it's like the first time I
feel like seems like that sure in like
yeah in a show or something
in general in the show but how do
pictures just different but yeah he's in
high school now and I feel like you see
the difference like from first season to
fourth season it's a big difference but
like huge the thing I can feel the most
is just like how he's like he doesn't
care that much you know he's like he
doesn't care about his hair so much okay
he's settling into it yeah maybe you'll
see in the season some look some change
of looks what does that mean it's been a
couple years on this show and it's
pretty wild that we've really grown up
with both of you how have your lives
changed over the last couple years Wow
well a lot how well I know when I got
the call from like when I found out
about one of your time my parents like
picked me up in my leg middle school and
we went out like for Froyo oh and in the
back of like the card they had written
like welcome to Netflix I was
I was running around and I was nervous
like for the first show that was twelve
I know and now you're a things they are
a man Oh
the first no I see a very mature young
man in front of me I do know he's a good
actor
well you guys are siblings on and off
screen truly but the first season or one
at a time I would feel like I was gonna
throw up every time we were gonna like
film like every episode I was going to
set like super scared and now I'm like
no it's just really fun and playing
around do you think the show made you
more confident oh for sure it's been
like a school to me week I've learned
not only so much about acting with I
mean like I've taught him everything he
knows
of course always and also I mean about
life all the life lessons that this show
has to teach and just family and and
making Latinos on TV normal which is
amazing totally how has your life
changed I mean I was 17 with my first
audition happened and now I'm 22 so I
matured a lot and grown up a lot on the
show and ya know started voting and like
bought a house in the car and go girl
you're full grown adult in like a
child's body like if you look at season
one Marcel is a completely different
person and I look exactly the same it's
crazy I mean you both know you've both
grown up and you definitely look more
mature now in season four but it's but
it's been really nice to watch the
Alvarez kids kind of growth you know
behind our TV screens
can you guys make a plea to our cameras
and ask your dream guest star to please
come on the show Lin I've asked this
every season please dear God we just
need your fruit like three hours and we
can shoot you out you don't even have to
be here for a whole week and we all love
you so please you know in a chill and
professional way who's comfortable just
this is a very professional way of
asking you to please guest sir yeah I
know you want to so
first why not
[Music]